the FBI has concluded its report
Republicans say they found no evidence
of wrongdoing from Brett Kavanaugh yeah
and they apparently interviewed everyone
Mitch McConnell Donald Trump I mean you
name it they everybody they talked to
Lindsey Graham when C Graham said I
didn't see a thing I mean they went nope
they talked to seven people who are
Republicans white males Democrats are
criticizing the FBI's investigation of
Brett Kavanaugh calling it a cover-up
yeah meanwhile Republicans are praising
the FBI's investigation of Brett
Kavanaugh calling it a cover-up and a
very good one there's all these stories
lately about Trump and maybe how he made
his money was who as for or didn't know
didn't take his money it's reported that
president Trump's older sister Mary Ann
may have been a key source in the New
York Times story about his past tax
evasion his older sister yeah probably
the two had a falling out after Trump
traded her in for a younger hotter
sister
[Music]
you know that was an option
ah this is what you probably have
experienced this yesterday Instagram
underwent a worldwide outage for nearly
an hour do you realize what that means
for almost 60 minutes the Kardashians
technically did not exist suddenly I
felt younger and I was floating wyneth
Paltrow's in the news Gweneth Paltrow
revealed that years ago her father once
called her out for becoming a Hollywood
[ __ ] Gwyneth said that prompted me to
change my ways and start selling Jade
vagina eggs
don't not get you tried it in Tennessee
officials say that 400 guns were stolen
from a UPS facility yeah
police are now looking for someone in
Tennessee who only has 400 guns that's
thank you
[Laughter]
I like that little little something and
then a little afterwards yeah hey
there's this crazy store there was chaos
in Dublin Ireland after the grand
opening of its first Krispy Kreme
Doughnuts they had a grant yes yeah
witnesses say the Irish got into
fistfights and street brawls then they
saw the Krispy Kreme
[Applause]
[Music]
this is how we all fight over there Andy
or how you stretch taffy taffy
you